Imagine that you are in charge of a company and are hiring for a new position.
Here are the candidates.
Without thinking about it too much, which one would you choose?
My guess is that you went for one of those in the middle...
...and avoided the people on the ends.
Why?
Because research shows that we tend to unconsciously think...
...those towards the middle of a group are more important.
Some of the work has examined the TV quiz show "The Weakest Link",...
...in which contestants stand in a semicircle and vote one another off.
Those standing towards the middle of the semicircle...
...won the game on average 45 percent of the time,...
...whilst those standing on one of the ends won just ten percent of the time.
So if you want to make a good impression during a meeting,...
...make certain you sit towards the middle of the group.